you could not live with your own failure
where did that bring you
to me what if Avengers infinity war and
Avengers in game really weren't what you
thought they were about at all what if I
told you that thanasis plan wasn't
really his plan and that he was just a
mere puppet to a much greater and more
powerful cosmic entity Galactus we all
know that the future of the MCU is
heading towards the cosmic future and
it's pretty much all but confirmed that
Galactus is coming and it appears that
Thanos could have simply been doing his
dirty work in Avengers infinity war and
Avengers endgame in this video I'm going
to go over several key points that make
us believe that Thanos was actually the
Herald of Galactus and now that he's
gone Galactus is on his way there are
many reasons to thank this famous
actually operates just like a Herald of
Galactus would he wielded infinite power
but then destroyed it
why and that unexplained sword that he
had an Avengers endgame makes sense now
too with fan osteen Galactus is Herald
the Marvel Cinematic Universe does
nothing by accident everything is
intertwined that's the beauty of the MCU
and if you don't think that Marvel set
up the future of the MCU during Avengers
infinity war and Avengers in game
I'd consider rethinking that Thanos was
the perfect villain and obviously Marvel
was not going to do a shot-for-shot
remake of the Infinity Gauntlet saga
where Thanos was killing half of the
universe to impress Lady Death instead
they created a new story arc for Thanos
one that made him an even more perfect
villain he was calm cool collected
powerful led an army he had never killed
any of the Avengers unless he had to and
he had strong conviction but what was
his conviction in his plan doesn't
really line up with why he is supposedly
saving the universe and maybe that's
because it's not actually his plan if it
were Thanos's plan it would be extremely
flawed and the mad Titan is a genius so
that's really not likely Screen Rant has
pointed out a major flaw in fan s's plan
that nobody has seemed to examine yet
and that flaw is that in his approach to
wipe out half of the life in the
universe and a single instant or balance
it as he says fails to take into account
the rate of which the population of the
universe is growing which is exponential
for example take earth which has a
population of somewhere around seven
point seven billion so if Thanos cut it
in half with the snap then he reduce
to 3.85 billion now this was the
planet's population in the late 1960s
that means that it only took 58 years
for the planet's population to grow by
3.8 5 billion people now obviously the
snap will have set humanity back a
little bit but as we saw in Avengers in
game just through the five-year gap
people have already began to recover and
move on this means that the population
numbers will soon again rise and it
probably won't be at the exact same
growth rate but you can expect the
population to double between 60 to 100
years this means that thanasis plan
didn't really fix anything at all it
simply delayed the inevitable for about
60 to 100 years and that's just earth
some other planets will grow much
quicker and Fanus would have had to have
known this especially since he clearly
understands the growth rate of the
population since he is seeking to
destroy half of the life of the universe
based on the fact that it's growing too
quickly for its resources and to make
matters worse he destroyed the Infinity
stones and he did this willingly saying
that they provided nothing more than a
temptation for others who would seek to
reverse what he had done he used the
stones to destroy the stones nearly
killed me but the work is done
it always will be the snap was just a
temporary fix and Thanos had to have
known that but then he destroyed the
only thing that could do it again even
by his own logic he had not saved the
universe he simply delayed the
inevitable and the reason for that is he
wasn't actually trying to save the
universe he was simply preserving it for
about 60 to 100 years to give somebody
more time to show up Galactus the
Devourer of worlds
Thanos was simply reducing the
population of the universe so that the
planets didn't die like fantasies did
that way Galactus could take his time
going planet to planet feeding off of
the life energy that they give and there
is evidence that backs this up as I
mentioned before
Thanos actually operates in a very
similar way to the way that the heralds
of Galactus operate Galactus chooses
heralds who he grants partial access to
the power cosmic who he charges with the
task of going out and finding planets
for him to devour the herald that
Galactus chooses is typically already an
extremely powerful being which of course
we know Fanus is being part eternal and
part deviant in avengers endgame he
managed to take on three of the
mightiest Avengers Iron Man Captain
America and Thor who is a god Thor even
had Stormbreaker and Captain America
even had Munir but Fano still
single-handedly managed to defeat them
this is a power level comparable to some
of the heralds of Galactus such as Nova
the Silver Surfer and tyrant just to
name a few
it's also worth noting that in Avengers
endgame Thanos wielded a weapon a very
mysterious double-edged sword that
nobody could figure out there was a lot
of talk about it before in-game came out
because it was never mentioned before
and an Avengers endgame it wasn't even
addressed but we do know that it was
able to break Captain America shield
which is made out of vibranium which is
supposed to be indestructible
it was even able to take on Thor
Stormbreaker which if you think about it
is very interesting Stormbreaker was
supposed to be the greatest weapon of
all time forged for the king of Asgard
by the dwarves of neduvaali r it's made
out of a room metal which is even
stronger than vibranium and is supposed
to be the strongest metal in the entire
universe it has the power to summon the
Bifrost and even has the potential to
destroy planets so this is a very very
powerful sword and clearly there is some
story behind it there have been many
different theories about fan OSIS sword
but the truth could very well lie with
Galactus as I mentioned before Galactus
grants a portion of the power cosmic to
his heralds and some of them are even
given weapons to help them channel the
power cosmic giving them insane
abilities that come with these weapons
and items obviously the most notable of
all of the items that have been given to
the heralds of Galactus is the silver
surfers board much like Galactus gave
the board to the Silver Surfer it's very
well that Galactus could have given fan
owes his double-edged sword
this would also explain why we never saw
a nose with the sword in Avengers
infinity war when we solve a nose for
the first time in Avengers infinity war
he already had the Infinity Gauntlet and
the Power Stone once Thanos got the
Infinity Gauntlet that could have been
what he used to harness the power of not
only the Infinity stones but the power
of the power cosmic as well this could
be why we never saw fan OSes sword in
Avengers infinity war the sword served
the purpose of harnessing the power
cosmic that Galactus gave Thanos but as
soon as he got the Infinity Gauntlet it
harnessed the power cosmic and all of
the power that came with it instead of
the sword and Galactus could have
actually been the one who told Thanos
about the Infinity stones in the first
place fan oohs clearly saw that the
universe was destined to be doomed which
meant in turn that his master Galactus
would eventually die as well Galactus
could have told Thanos about the
Infinity stones and charged him with the
task of slowing down the population
growth of the universe that way Galactus
would have enough time to go about the
universe consuming planet after planet
not having to worry about any of them
dying before he got to them and the
Infinity Gauntlet could have served more
than one purpose for Thanos and Galactus
yes it was a way for Thanos to eliminate
half of the life in the universe or slow
the population growth down
but let's not forget that vanos
destroyed it again even if it was
theosis plan to eliminate half of the
life in the universe to save the
universe it was a very flawed plant and
Thanos would have had to have seen that
and if it was truly his destiny why
would he risk not having the Infinity
Gauntlet and the Infinity stones around
to be able to protect himself and
protect his plan in case somebody tried
to undo it
aka The Avengers especially since they
have gotten in the way of some of his
plans in the past so destroying the
Infinity stones was completely
irrational and unlogical and that's just
not how Thanos works he's a very logical
and rational person so why did he
destroy the stones well it's probably
because his mission was done not his
mission to save the universe by killing
half of the life in it but his mission
to slow down the growth rate of the
universe so Galactus could have time to
arrive every time that Thanos used the
combined powers of all six Infinity
stones he generated a surge of cosmic
energy that could have served as a
beacon to Galactus drawing him into a
new feeding ground and then when he
destroyed the Infinity stones that could
have been the ultimate signal to
Galactus a signal that says I have
completed my mission master and the
instruction to destroy the Infinity
stones most likely came from Galactus as
well if Galactus told Thanos about the
power of the Infinity stones then he
knows that the Infinity Gauntlet with
all of the Infinity stones combined is
probably the only weapon that could
actually defeat Galactus so Galactus is
final order to fan oohs could have been
to use the Infinity stones to destroy
the Infinity stones which is what Thanos
did that way there would be no way to
defeat Galactus when he would show up
Galactus is said to be the next big bad
villain of the MCU that could arrive
within the next 10 years and even if all
of these connections weren't done
intentionally it's very clear that
there's a way to retcon Galactus into
the MCU and have all of the events
throughout the Infinity Saga connect to
him which of course that's what Marvel
will do because that's what the MCU is
fan o's could have very well been The
Herald of Galactus he was simply
preserving the population long enough so
Galactus could arrive and devour the
planets himself if this is true then the
Avengers will definitely have their
hands full when they go up against
Galactus within the next 10 years of the
MCU
they will definitely need the help of
the x-men and the Fantastic Four if they
want to have any type
chance of defeating him so let me know
what you think about this theory in the
comments down below do you think that
Thanos could have been the Herald of
Galactus and Avengers infinity war and
Avengers endgame also don't forget to
like the video if you enjoyed the theory
and subscribe to my channel so you can
enter my giveaway for a chance to win an
Xbox one or a ps4 as always thank you
all so much for watching
woof woof